[Music]
session will focus on the future of
space exploration appropriately our
moderator for this session is Professor
Edward Crawley Ed's the director of the
Burnie Gordon
MIT engineering leadership program he's
also a Ford professor of engineering and
he has appointments in both the
Department of aeronautics and
Astronautics and engineering systems
Ed's research focuses on the domain of
architecting and designing complex
technical systems and he spent a great
deal of time looking at Arctic
architecting complex technical space
systems in particular
he's a former department head in Aero
and Astro and I had the pleasure of
serving as his deputy during part of
that time he is also on the Augustine
Commission which has recently been named
so he has a very unique role in looking
at the future of vision for Space
Exploration Edie
thank you in space has become a
ubiquitous capability in our lifetime we
drive around with GPS in our cars watch
television shows that were beamed down
by from satellite transceivers we get
scientific results back from space we
monitor the condition of the climate of
the earth from space all of these things
are accomplishments of the past and
hopefully will carry on into the future
what we are going to be discussing in
this panel session is the future of
space and of space exploration but
before we go to that I want to point out
just how ubiquitous the success of space
has become in popular American culture
since the advent of satellite radio I'd
become a country music fan not something
that a boy who grew up in New England
would likely to have happen if you just
had to listen to regular AM and FM radio
so I was a beep up and down the road one
day listening to this Rodney Atkins song
and here's the refrain the song is
called it's America these are all the
iconographic images of America a high
school prom a spring seats teen song a
ride in a Chevrolet a man on the moon
fireflies in June and kids selling
lemonade cities and farms open arms one
nation under God it's America we're
gonna hear it now
man what a picture-perfect Coast Guard
this would make America
[Music]
it's America now the interesting thing
is that I listen to that song tens of
times and I could have sworn that that
line said it's a man on the moon in five
flights and I said seven eight nine ten
eleven boy this Rodney Atkins guy he
really knows his face history but of
course it actually when I was preparing
the script concert sounds to read a man
on the moon and fireflies in June I have
three laws on Space Flight Kepler and I
have three mine might be more useful the
the first while reveal the three of them
to you over the course of this session
the first one is there are many
uncertainties in the future of
spaceflight but the one thing I can say
with confidence is that every two years
there will be a congressional election
and every four years of presidential
election so space missions and space
programs must be designed to
continuously demonstrate of value to the
American people in a demonstrable way
and an ANA cadence that's associated
with this pattern one of the
unquestionable sources of the delivery
of value to the American people is in
the scientific space program and our
first speaker today who will address
that in her keynote is Maria Zuber the
professor and head of the MIT Department
of Earth atmospheric and Planetary
Sciences a member of the Aldrich
Commission in 2004 which chartered the
initial direction of the vision for
Space Exploration sort of the bookend
the one that I'm now going to spend my
summer vacation working on she's also
the principal investigator of the Grail
mission this is mi t--'s mission which
will tend to send to scientific
spacecraft to do gravity mapping of the
moon in the year 2011 Rhea
great thank you very much you have no
idea how excited I am to be here today
last fall
Ian and I got together he said he wanted
to talk to me and he his opening comment
was run and hide I need your help and
then he told me about this event and
what he wanted to do and we came up with
the ideas for the women in aerospace
event in the Sally Ride science event
and how could you stay away from these
things what uh what an honor it is my
parents let me stay up late to watch the
Apollo 11 astronauts walk on the moon
I wrote long letters to every Apollo
astronaut telling them my impressions of
the missions and and asking them about
theirs and none of you guys ever
answered me
but every time I sent a letter NASA sent
me an autographed picture of the
astronauts from the the mission and and
I took that as great encouragement and
I'm still around so it doesn't take much
to encourage and inspire okay today in
the short time I have available I want
to just offer some thoughts about about
how to move ahead okay and I thought I
would start here with a recipe of what I
consider to be success my experience has
been in robotic spacecraft I've flown
over a half a dozen experiments and I
have several experiments in space right
now so but I wanted to give this talk I
think to do honor and justice to the the
magnitude of this event to think more
broadly about than just my own field but
to think about the full suite of science
that might be possible and also to bring
into that human spaceflight so so what's
the recipe for success in future space
exploration well I think certainly there
needs to be exploration and discovery
every time we've ever been somewhere
that we haven't been or we've ever
looked at something with a different set
of eyes or a different wavelength or a
different spectral resolution we've
discovered something so discovery is
assured when we go out and look I also
think very practically speaking that
it's very important that we contribute
to human wellbeing and certainly the
capabilities that we have in space
contribute to that and just to give you
an example from what we saw this morning
the image of earth rise taken by Apollo
8 as it came from behind the moon and
the image of the
Earth's the jack Schmidt took looking
back at the earth as Apollo 17 went to
the moon
I think profoundly changed the way about
people thought think about the earth and
certainly contributed in a very positive
way to our humanity and and so those are
just two examples but there are many
practical examples as well any any
program that we have for space
exploration really needs to be reality
based it's great to be a dreamer but the
only good space mission is one that's in
space really working so the greatest
ideas that one can come up with for all
the wonderful things that one can do if
they're not practical and they're not
implementable then then their time has
not yet come and and I'm very much a
person who likes to think about the
future but live for the present we need
a mixed portfolio nASA has gotten into
trouble in the past by going to all big
missions and then going to all small
missions and and I will describe a
number of examples of mixture of small
focused objectives and large grandiose
things that can only be done with major
major technology investment the
combination of those two I think leads
will lead to a healthy program and so in
keeping with that I think balancing
spaceflight heritage and technology
development in order to get the the best
people excited about being a part of the
space program
you can't just simply take off-the-shelf
hardware Andry fly at every single time
okay although for some applications
spaceflight heritage is of course very
useful but if you only flow what you fly
what you've flown before you'll never
fly anything actually because nothing
will have ever flown
human the human presence in space I'm a
huge fan of the human space program but
I think the human presence in space
should be four objectives which are
worth risk and so in this way I echo
some of the comments that we've heard
earlier today I believe that humans and
robots should work in space together to
their optimal advantage I believe that
things that could be done by robots
should be done by robots but there are
plenty of things that humans can bring
to spaceflight exploration the robot
can't bring and I'll give you an example
of just one of those things and and I
think it's also crucial that we inspire
and train the next generation when I was
on the Aldrich Commission we traveled
around the country we held town meetings
and we held hearings and I was
absolutely astonished at the hundreds
and hundreds of people who came up to me
and told me how they became interested
in being a scientist or an engineer
because of getting to watch the Apollo
missions and and it's it's a non
quantifiable arrangement by and large I
can't remember any of these people that
actually worked for the space program
they were telecom engineers they were
biologists they were electrical
engineers but they realized that the
math and science that they took in
school could just have really a
magnificent application of doing things
that they were good at and and what you
don't see in here in the Aldrich
Commission one of the things that we
found is is that certainly national
prestige international cooperation all
of these things if you do all these
things the rest will follow and all of
these will contribute okay so in the 20
minutes
that I've been allotted we we can't
possibly cover all of what could be done
in space exploration so I'm just going
to choose a number of examples and talk
about them at a very high level in some
cases they deal with particular missions
or programs that have been suggested in
decadal studies or in commissions in
other cases I think that they would just
be interesting questions to study it's
not at all clear that all of these could
be done certainly in any particular
sequence and I do believe very very
strongly in in presidential vision and
in community input and bringing all of
that together to bring together a great
program so so this is this is not going
to be comprehensive by any stretch of
the imagination but illustrative of some
of the points that I listed in the last
slide so so a bold diverse agenda in
space could study human physiology
measure the variability of the Sun
determine the extent and composition of
the universe discover other Earth's in
other solar systems sustain our planet
and seek extraterrestrial life and I
will give you an example or two of each
of these examples okay
so human physiology and behavior okay
this is basically this is just an
example I mean two things by what I I'd
like to talk about here the first is
that if humans are going to have a
long-term presence in space and I
believe that they should then we're
gonna have to monitor physiological and
behavioral effects over the long term
this is taking place now it needs to
continue to take place
I think putting in people into space
just to do this is probably not
justification of itself in the risk but
doing other interesting things certainly
this kind of information should be
collected the the second point that I
mean by this slide is to say that to
follow on John Holdren comments from the
last session and to say that we really
need to think about a plan for the
International Space Station a great deal
of effort was has been and is being
invested in in assembling it in space it
is an absolutely magnificent facility
I believe there are one or more nobel
prizes to be won
with science that could be done on the
space station for the reasons that I
talked to before about being an
environment that you're not in and
studying something that you haven't
studied before I'm not sure if that
Nobel Prize is in the physical sciences
the biological sciences or someplace
else but but I think thinking about how
to make use of this facility that we
have invested so much and in good
cooperation with international partners
I think is an extremely worthy goal the
variability of the Sun okay the Sun the
behavior of the Sun is important for so
many reasons okay and we have only been
able to measure solar irradiance from a
spacecraft since the late 1970s with the
Nimbus 7 spacecraft and it looks like
there are decayed all variations in
solar variability and and certainly this
comes into questions about what is the
role of the Sun in climate in terms of
what the flux of the Sun is and also
what is the effect of the Sun on the
upper atmosphere on convective patterns
clouds etc
a solar predictability another reason
that we need to understand the Sun is
that successful robotic and human
exploration will require the prediction
of space weather in the heliosphere and
this is a beautiful picture of the solar
photosphere by by the Tres mission but
the the interesting thing about this so
this is this is a very practical
application about a measurement that is
going to be very important if we're
going to send humans into space for
extended period if we want to think
about an outpost on the moon but it's a
very interesting scientific question as
well because the Sun the heliosphere the
earth and the planets form a coupled
system through a whole variety of space
physics processes and trying to
understand the interaction between those
processes and how they all fit together
is just a fascinating systems problem
with the recent flyby data that we've
collected from the messenger spacecraft
at Mercury the coupling that we're
seeing between the heliosphere and the
surface and and Mercury's magneto the
sheath it's just fascinating how dynamic
what people thought this was a dead
planet but there's actually a great
amount of dynamicism that is taking
place and understanding this I think is
just a fascinating scientific problem
okay we're now going to move on to
astrophysics and in fact we're going to
move on to the edge of the universe so
the universe is somewhere between 13
point 5 and 14 billion years old and and
we have a mission that will be launching
hopefully on about the 2014 timeframe
the James Webb Space Telescope this will
have this will be at the l2 point one
point five million kilometers from the
Sun away from
the distraction of the earth and and
this mission will actually be able to
measure or detect an image the first
galaxies that formed after the Big Bang
what a fascinating thing to do to go
back and see the universe in its
formative stages okay that doesn't
appear to be working okay
what I was going to show on that slide
and I'll just talk about it if I can
remember what I was going to say was the
constitution of the universe and one of
the fascinating observations that we
have made and about the last decade or
so actually it's been a variety of
independent observations has been the
suggestion of a force called dark energy
which would make up about three-quarters
of the mass of the universe so it turns
out that there's a disconnect between
the geometry of the universe and the
amount of matter that we know about and
and this has been determined from Hubble
Space Telescope observations of type 1a
supernova stars as well as measurements
of anisotropy in the universe this is a
map of the Cosmic Microwave Background
by the W map spacecraft and it shows
that the universe is basically flat
which is basically calling for something
with negative pressure to be filling the
abyss or else something quite unusual
happening like a breakdown of the
inverse square law of gravity at large
distances and this gets down to the
basic question of exactly what is the
universe made of and it is a very worthy
goal for future exploration okay next I
don't think I have to tell anybody about
the excitement of directly detecting and
characterizing terrestrial planets
beyond the earth there are suggestions
of mission called a terrestrial planet
finder which
think about two ways of detecting
planets terrestrial type planets around
other stars so if you have a terrestrial
planet around a star in another system
there's there's a variation in
brightness of about 10 to the 10th over
a distance of a fraction of an arcsecond
and so it turns out to be incredibly
setting to separate the two and and
there's two ideas for doing this one is
to put an internal coronagraph in a
spacecraft to block out the central star
the other calls for a nulling
interferometer where we put spacecraft
flying in formation and very tight
formation in which we we have the light
coming in about a half wavelength apart
so we can have destructive interference
and cancel out light that way and
terrestrial planet finder these two
aspects of it have been in planning some
time but there is there is not really
sufficient funding in the budget to move
ahead with it we want to do more than
simply detect planets around other stars
we like to characterize their gases so
we have here Mars and Venus where we can
see the co2 atmosphere that both of
those planets have but we're really
looking for the signature of gases in
the atmosphere that looked like they
could be produced by biological activity
which for the case of the earth is ozone
so we certainly want to do that if
something like the terrestrial planet
finder can't be done in the very near
term because of reasons of cost there
are some interesting simpler approaches
that are being suggested here is a paper
that was published a couple of years ago
in nature for an occult er that could
actually be placed externally to to a
telescope and if one put one of these
petal shaped the cultures for in a
twenty to thirty meter a culture in
front of the James Webb Space Telescope
one could actually and Mun move
seven parsecs from our solar system one
would actually be able to to image Earth
and Mars so these are the kinds of
things that could be done within about a
decade even with with a somewhat
constrained budget okay I want to move
on to earth exploration and and one of
the things that I have been a very very
strong proponent for is a renewed
commitment to observation of the earth I
think it is essential that we take up
and rejuvenate earth monitoring and John
Holdren gave some examples about the
gaps that are there and it is very
pleasing to see that the administration
is taking this very seriously I'm going
to give you just one example of the kind
of monitoring that would be very useful
to do and and believe me there's there's
quite a bit more than this this is an
image of the Antarctic continent and and
we really need to make very quantitative
measurements with small error bars about
how ice sheet volume is changing and
about how ice sheets are flowing so here
are are some measurements of estimations
of ice sheet flow we don't have these
going on on a regular basis we have
conflicting estimates of what ice sheet
volumes are there are some ideas of
missions that could go in and and
measure this very precisely this is the
the Destiny mission which is an L band
interfere metric radar system which
could go in and measure that and we want
to know the flow properties we want to
know the amount of water within the ice
sheets we want to know about the lakes
that are forming beneath the ice sheets
which we're making attempts to must
estimate but it's done basically by
field
because this lowers the viscosity at the
the base of the ice sheet and it
accelerates slip reduces friction and
accelerates slip and accelerates flow of
the ice sheets into the oceans and and
it appears that the ice sheets are
decreasing in magnitude faster than the
models predict and this is a part of it
and it is something that we need to
understand so this is a plot of this is
an orbital radar measurement of ice cap
layering it's a about 700 or so
kilometers across and this is actually a
figure that I showed in a talk last week
in out in Chicago and and it's it's
actually the planet Mars it's not the
earth okay and and I had somebody raise
their hand at the end of the talk and
say could you please convince NASA to
fly one of these around the earth so
that we could get the same kind of
measurements for the earth that we have
now for Mars and and we have in fact
also measured from a satellite snow
accumulation over the seasons on Mars
before we have done that for the earth
so there's a variety of things that
we've been able to do for the planets
that we haven't been able to do for
Earth so when we talk about challenges
and opportunities one of the things that
we can think about okay so we've taken
quite a number of observations of Mars
over the past decade and a half or so in
some ways doing Mars is easier than
Earth in some ways doing it is harder
it's farther away from the Sun it's
harder to get to there's a lower solar
flux so it makes it more challenging to
power instruments so you need lower
power instruments you have more issues
with data rate you have higher surface
gravity on the earth than you do on Mars
Earth has an atmosphere which is
problematic in terms of how low and
orbiting spacecraft
can orbit because drag decreases the
size of the orbit earth has a surface
ocean which causes complications Mars
has no surface ocean although it has
appears to have a frozen underground sea
on earth we have the advantage of a GPS
constellation which is essential in
helping us with positioning and we don't
have the advantage of that on earth but
here I think is what I think is the
biggest advantage of working on Mars up
into the earth on earth there's national
companies security concerns with some of
the observations that you take and
there's politics about making some
measurements that would be controversial
or not favorable for business interests
and and those problems don't occur for
Mars I do both earth research and and
planetary research and it is so much
easier to make the case to send an
instrument to another planet than it is
on earth and something is fundamentally
wrong about that and and so I really
very hopeful that in the new
presidential administration that we're
going to set that right finally I want
to talk about the challenge of finding
life beyond Earth and I said seek life
beyond Earth not necessarily find it
because we don't actually know that it's
there but whether it is or not is very
fascinating and let me just give you a
few examples of fantastic places to look
so first of all the planet Titan which
is being magnificently revealed by the
Cassini spacecraft which is in its
extended mission Titan is the only other
planetary body in the solar system that
has a nitrogen atmosphere like the earth
the radar observations of Cassini have
shown the presence of liquid methane
lakes at high latitudes on that
planetary body it would be a fascinating
place to land on the surface and look
for evidence of carbon-based
life forms in the outer solar system
Europa we now have very good evidence
from magnetic induction measurements
that have been taken by the Galileo
spacecraft that there is a subsurface
ocean around Europa this is an area of
Europa called Cana monic chaos the big
question is how deep is this ocean
beneath the surface and is this ocean
accessible so this is an area that
appears pretty frozen and actually as an
analogy this is a Landsat image I
believe of an area off the Wilkens
Ice Sheet in Antarctica which has very
many morphological similarities to this
area on Europa and and this area here
has occurred where the ice has slid off
the Antarctic continent and then ice
blocks have have tilted over and so
where this these different colors that
you see here correspond to the presence
of salts and which indicates that the
water below had contact with the surface
we don't know how long ago it is but
certainly looking for thin areas on the
ice and this is a very non readable
chart but estimates range from hundreds
of meters in some places to many tens of
kilometers and and that would it would
be extremely challenging to get to but
very much worth it and then finally the
the last area that I'll talk about is is
looking for life in the subsurface of
Mars so this is this is what I'll call
the frozen subsurface sea on Mars and
this what you see right here this is a
map of not water it is a map of neutron
flux and where you see blue means that
there is a lack of neutrons being
emitted from the surface neutrons yeah
mitad due to the imposition of cosmic
rays onto the surface and water
moderates neutrons and it picks them up
and makes heavy water so when you see a
lack of neutrons it's a good bet that
there's water beneath the surface and
this is the instrumentation here which
is on the Mars Odyssey spacecraft which
is currently operating indicates that in
some places there is more than 70
percent by volume water ice in the top
meter of the surface we don't know
exactly how deep this goes
but as you go deeper on Mars Mars is
very marginal Mars has a very fractured
surface because it has been impacted
there is the thought that that the crust
is very fractured which makes it a
fantastic reservoir so if Mars had a
surface water ocean or lakes that there
could be water that was on the surface
that is deep in the crust and if it has
the porosity and permeability similar to
the moon that we measured during Apollo
it's easy to fit an ocean beneath the
surface but the best place to look for
life I would argue is where you where
it's warm and where it's still warm and
so the idea is to go to Mars and drill
and this is where you could really use
humans so this is a place where humans
would contribute very very significantly
in a way that that a robot would have a
difficult time doing and so so I'll just
close by saying you know the things that
I've talked about range from very very
doable almost routine from a spaceflight
basis to being what I'll call flagship
class to you know perhaps a submarine on
Europa and that's that's pretty
long-range and very difficult to do but
the question of of could we send people
to Mars and could this be done in the
next 40 years whenever I design a space
flight mission I sit down and I try to
sketch out how many miracles do I need
and if it's more than two I work on
something else for a while
okay and because there's only so many
things
that you can solve and get your
experimented to space so so we're going
to have a new crew vehicle we need a
heavy lock lift launch vehicle we need a
surface module we need a whole class of
new space suits that allow astronauts
sufficient mobility with that allow that
they don't get weighed down and tired
Mars has a higher G than the moon and
it's very rocky in many places so we
need to think about the physiology there
and some of this work is actually going
on at MIT and making good progress in
this area and we need transportation so
there's a lot more than two miracles
technologically that are in this slide
but let me just close here by saying
what a wonderful thing that it would be
I believe these technological problems
could be solved because smart people
want to work on them and I'm just going
to close here with hopeful thought this
is a this is a picture of Earth taken
from the surface of Mars from the mars
exploration rover landing sites and
imagine the idea that maybe one of the
students who are sitting in the
auditorium today could see this site for
themselves within the next several
decades thank you very much
so Thank You Maria for that tour de
force I'm since we're talking about the
future of space exploration we're gonna
use a technology of the present rather
than the past and take questions that
are texted to my phone so the text
number will now appear so all of you who
know how to do this go ahead and ask
questions and the rest of you should
learn I see the first text question has
come in it says a professor's uber if
you were hypothetically to advise a
member of the Augustine committee on the
priorities of humans and robotics
working together within the Earth Moon
Mars system how would you rank those
priorities within within the Earth Moon
Mars system
okay so texting because that was mine
okay all right great
okay so um so so actually one of the
things that I think would be fascinating
is I'm Farah I'm I think it's important
that humans have access to low Earth
orbit because once you're in low Earth
orbit you're out of the gravitational
well and then you can do anything you
want basically but I I would like so but
I would like to see humans get out of
low Earth orbit and
and even in the earth-moon l1 l2 system
I think is a is a good place to be and
and I think it's worth giving some
thought I was very inspired thinking
about the thought of seeing the earliest
universe when I was doing some reading
in preparation for this talk and and
there's been some thoughts about
deployable mirrors and inflatable
mirrors and and people are thinking
about these aerospace companies are
thinking about these university
researchers and and and I think that
humans could be quite enabling in these
things we had humans fix Hubble and
fortunately they were able to do that
there were thoughts about actually
repairing Hubble robotically and I
remember during the Aldrich Commission
seeing fantastic video about how a robot
would do it and and the people trying to
push this said it would be cheaper than
a shuttle flight and and there was no
way that that could happen but I think
in the earth mmm l1 l2 system humans in
space could be deploying new kinds of
mirrors that would have vast observing
power human Phobos mission would it be
worth sending humans to rendezvous with
Phobos and bring back samples
Phobos the moon Phobos yes it it
certainly it certainly could be done and
it's certainly feasible would I would I
recommend doing that over something else
I what I would do is being a practical
person I would look at the technological
feasibility of doing that versus
something else and and I would you know
I'm I'm all for doing what you can do
rather than then something that's more
difficult to do how do you think a
layperson can best support the space
program I have about 20 now by the way
I'm taking gonna take two or three more
how will a person can best support the
space program I well vote okay and and
you've you've all done that most of you
people have because we had a great
outcome in the in the election you know
I think people just bye-bye their
appreciation of of what's gone on their
participation in the blog's their
support of Education all of that really
contributes to the space program I use
at the South Pole of the moon what do I
think about ice at the South we're gonna
find it when we smash into it ah well
I'm sending an experiment to look for it
next week so
so we got that one taken care of pretty
fast but but I'll talk about it so so
there's there's hydrogen at the South
Pole of the moon okay but what-what
doesn't get a lot of airplay
is that there's hydrogen in areas of the
Moon that see sunlight every month okay
and so to me the big question is is this
hydrogen ice or is it implanted solar
wind nuclei and the fact that you see
hydrogen in areas that are are not
shaded most of the time suggests to me
that solar wind is at least a part of it
so and I tend to take things
conservatively but I also believe in in
actually collecting data last question
why do we keep focusing on Mars why
don't we spend more time on Venus
well venus is a great so there there has
been remarkable Mars program for about
the last decade and a half and I feel
very gifted and honored to have been a
part of that there was a remarkable
mission to Venus in in the early 90s the
Magellan mission that mapped the surface
I believe in the budget rollout that
Mars is not going to be its own program
anymore at least there's discussion out
of it and and Mars is going to be
considered in the context with the rest
of the solar system so that may address
that question that the person has but
what I will say is that before Venus had
its greenhouse if it had the right cloud
cover and before it lost its
water it actually models indicate that
for a period of time it actually could
have been quite Clement so if we're
looking for a planet where there was
past life you know there's a small
chance we've been looking in the wrong
place thank you very much
by the way that produced about 16
questions or 16 questions or comments
including I like your tie so I'll invite
the panel now to come up here and as
they do I'll give you law number two of
my three laws of space flight no one is
likely to make money in space as opposed
to launching into space no one is likely
to make money in space moving atoms only
moving bits and photons if you notice
that virtually everything Maria talked
about it was images it was measurements
this is in the information sphere and
the question is will anybody ever make
money in space by doing something with
stuff with real molecules so for example
here's the question I posed to my
students in the space system design
class if you were to fly to the surface
of the Moon and find sitting there
something that you put into the your
spacecraft and brought it back to the
earth what would you have to be able to
sell it for at $1 per pound or dollars
per kilogram in order to make money as a
business proposition and what would that
substance be okay you can think about
that now I'll introduce our panel let's
see from when I this side is James
Garvin who's the NASA chief scientist
Chris Scalise was not able to be with us
today at the last minute there's a
Flight Readiness review resolutely so
Chris is doing the job of enacting it in
acting NASA Administrator being at the
Cape and we wish that process well James
Jeff Garvin is the NASA chief scientist
works on strategic issues at NASA
particularly in helping formulate the
vision for Space Exploration he worked
on the first orbiter based use of a
shuttle laser altimeter around the earth
and he is in fact leading the studies of
future missions to Venus Richard
Garriott is a computer game developer
and entrepreneur he's the son of own
Garriott who was a Skylab astronaut
which makes him the
first second-generation astronaut when
he flew as the 6th private citizen to go
to the International Space Station
recently and he's an investor in the
space business we'll have to ask him
about that
Erica Wagner is the science director of
the MIT Mars gravity by OSA she's an
alumna of the International Space
University and is the executive director
of the XPrize lab at MIT studying how to
incentivize the exploration of space
with you surprises Dave Thompson is the
chairman and CEO of orbital sciences
corporation is a successful I would say
space entrepreneur having founded the
company in 1982 based on a business plan
idea that he wrote while he was
finishing his degree at the Harvard
Business School our orbital has launched
over 700 rocket satellites and other
types of vehicles and Dave for his work
in the Pegasus program was awarded the
National Medal of Technology by
President Bush 41 Jim Crocker is the
vice president and general manager of
sensing and exploration systems for
Lockheed Martin's space he's responsible
for a wide range of business lines
associated with space missions and
spacecraft and among the things he's
worked on were the corrective optics for
the repair of the camera in the Hubble
Space Telescope and his team which by
the way Jeff Hoffman the moderator in
the morning was the one who installed
and his team successfully prepared the
Phoenix lander successfully bred and
landed the Phoenix lander on the North
Pole of Mars and then there's Murray at
the end so welcome
so we're going to follow the same format
that Ian did and just ask the sort of
the appropriate leading questions down
and we'll give everyone about five
minutes to respond and I'll take some
more questions at the end including some
of the ones that were texted in which
are really more appropriate for other
panel members so James what's NASA are
going to do in the future of space
exploration to help
well thanks ed can I have the clicker
since I thought images are sometimes
better well
NASA's programs of course were guided by
many of you in fact I thought before I
answer I would ask all the people in the
room that worked on Apollo or the Space
Shuttle or the International Space
Station to stand up because those of you
that did that have given us the legacy
the shoulders of thinking beyond and
let's have a little hand for these
colleagues they've done it thank you all
thank you so in crafting an answer then
if I may have the first slide Thanks I
think we have to look beyond Apollo and
remember that what Apollo was was pretty
much all of NASA at the time that it
went forward and in fact it was both
catalytic and it gave us the confidence
to do the next great thing and so what
did Nats are do next it diversified and
this is part of our if you will our
legacy from Apollo we diversified from
being on the moon and doing the great
science that Maria talked about to great
advances in propulsion and Aero thermal
engineering some know happened here at
MIT and the shuttle gave us maybe too
many people a mixed blessing it extended
human spaceflight to low-earth orbit and
it seems to some that we've been
grounded there or flying there forever
however that's not really the case it's
important to look at the record what did
shuttle do well its constructing
International Space Station our next
great natural aberrant National
Laboratory in space it also flew
missions of discovery the first ever
global map of most of the earth
topography was made from the shuttle in
a way that only the shuttle could enable
five servicing missions to Hubble
extending its life initially by Jeff and
others after it was broken this legacy
was a combination of human spaceflight
and robotic spaceflight that is really
the hallmark of NASA that we're now
proceeding with in addition I think we
need to remember that one of the things
NASA does best is to build capability
the science is done in the universities
and the National Laboratories the
capabilities that are now on the table
to be developed
for the extension of human presence in
space are all about those miracles that
Maria was talking about what do we need
to do that well we need access to space
you can't do things in space if you're
not in space I think my second grader
gets that even so given that access to
space needs to be assured one of the big
hallmarks for the last ten years was the
recognition that separating crew from
cargos important and hence a fleet of
Ares launch vehicles to carry both the
crew and an Orion capsule system
borrowed from the great legacy of Apollo
but also to a heavy-lift launch vehicle
the
Aries five to carry the consumables the
big stuff and in doing so also enabling
things that we could do robotically that
we can't do today with our current our
current fleet the other thing that's
very important to recognize in this
picture is the earth departure stage the
propulsion system that carries people
from beyond the gravity well to where
we're going is vital it worked
beautifully on Apollo Buzz's sitting
here absolutely got him home as
testament to that we haven't been back
to that kind of technology since those
days we don't have human-rated in space
propulsion systems so this capability
space I'm showing here is the plan for
NASA with the public support of this
administration to go forward and it will
leave the gaps that John and others
talked about earlier in addition we have
ideas beyond the that really focus on
looking at the earth as a system beyond
where we are today and Maria touched on
this we are in a revolution of
understanding the last 30 or 40 years of
the earth science record the National
Academy de kado Survey for earth science
recommended 15 new missions several with
revolutionary technologies I like to
show this picture because it looks weird
but it's an image of this mission called
destiny whose primary job of looking at
the ice is to measure basically the
sources and sinks of carbon and as we go
to a carbon offset economy and look at
cap and trades how much carbon aren't we
sequestering how much is there what is
the record of that carbon is it locked
up in the boreal masses or is it in the
ground how is it in the oceans we don't
know we have a missing carbon problem on
earth and it's not just the hydrocarbons
we burn missions like this and others
recommended by the decay toll survey are
in our future and this is an artist
concept of the 2015 destiny mission so
looking at the earth is very important
finally my last comments I'd like to
really talk about what's happened in the
last 40 years and look beyond so it was
to have been a Space Age we went to the
moon we did all the great things not
because they're easy but because they're
hard as President Kennedy said I can't
help but saying that it sounds good here
in Boston but but anyway what actually
happened was human spaceflight focused
on on arrow thermal engineering shuttles
and space stations and robotics based
like took over and
I'd like to show this picture of the
Mini Cooper sighs no offense to other
auto manufacturers in the room the Mini
Cooper sized Mars Science Lab now named
curiosity by a young girl what's
important about this picture is in 1972
many many not here but in other places
would not believe this is possible a
nine hundred and fifty kilogram
autonomous mobile analytical laboratory
carrying gear as sensitive as any in the
United States on the ground when the
Apollo samples came back in 69 that's in
that now and the price of this vehicle
is 1/6 the price of the Viking mission
we flew to Mars in 1976 in our first
foray to look for life beyond we have
gotten better and this is evidence of
what has been a robotic information age
as we've learned in human spaceflight to
now dream the bigger dreams so let me
conclude with a couple final thoughts
that echo Maria
Maria's comments about science I think
this picture says it all somewhere there
is a sweet spot and it's a realistic
sweet spot between the robotic
spaceflight that does the grand science
the Grand Challenges and the human
spaceflight that enables those and
whether it's drilling on Mars or
erecting gigantic inflatable telescopes
or in erecting giant apertures to look
back at earth to measure the radiative
balance and other drivers of our climate
or looking at the Sun you can all
imagine them better than I that's a
hallmark of our next 40 I think and
here's John Grunsfeld an MIT grad go
John doing what was not imaginable by
the robotic servicing plans that Maria
talked about after the Columbia disaster
and this all happened just two weeks ago
so this is our future and how to extend
this to the surface of the Moon or to a
neo or to Mars is is really the ultimate
question so I'd like to finish with one
final thought which is it's appropriate
here in Boston let me see the bridge
that ultimately the question comes down
to the capability to get there and earth
to orbit and orbit to space is what
we're all about in the next 40 I think
we'll see that revolution coming from
NASA thank you
Richard I actually have a question for
you to lead in this is a symptomatic of
the the future generation are you ready
for this
why does Richard still have a pad one
style haircut he's been in space now he
must be a Jedi Knight I think that
question must be referring to these my
little my rat tails here which I have to
tell you I've had since before it was
cool before Star Wars through the period
of time that was cool
during Star Wars and now long after so
for better or worse but but also earlier
you would ask me to talk about the role
of the real question yes the real which
is the you know what are the potential
roles of this fledgling new
entrepreneurial private space industry
that is that I've had a chance to play a
part in what's its role as this new era
is upon us
you know and I first have to start out
by just saying that you know I grew up
in a neighborhood believing that every
one of us was going to go to space I
mean my father was an astronaut and both
my right and left hand next-door
neighbors were astronauts back defense
my back fence was an astronaut Buzz and
Neil were nearby in the neighborhood you
know everyone was either an astronaut or
an engineer or scientist involved in
putting people into space so I grew up
you know I think lots of kids grew up
believing that they want to grow up to
be an astronaut I just assumed everybody
went because everybody I knew did go and
it was it was a real shock for me when I
was a young teenager in a NASA flight
medicine a NASA doctor actually told me
that my poor eyesight meant that I was
not eligible to be selected as an
astronaut and so at first it was
crushing as it was like being told you
are no longer eligible to be a member of
the club that your father and all of his
friends are members of after getting
over that shock I then decided well look
you know who are you one source NASA to
tell me that I have no no ability to go
to space
and so I said you know if I'm gonna go
it means I have to go privately and if
I'm gonna go privately it means a
private space industry has to come into
existence and being young enough not to
realize how incredibly difficult a
problem that was I set off as an
investor to bring into existence private
spaceflight and I was very fortunate
that at a young age I also discovered
computers and had a very successful
career in the computer game industry
that had mentioned but with all with
pretty much every dollar that I invested
personally I invested in the
privatization of space I invested first
in organizations like Spacehab which
part of their original business plan was
to put people and basically a
double-decker bus in the back of the
shuttle payload Bay before I realized
that the politics that made it
effectively impossible I invested a
number of the fledgling suborbital space
plane companies even before we started
something called the XPrize I was one of
the founding board members of the XPrize
founding supports the XPrize zero-g Corp
and ultimately space adventures which is
how I finally arranged my flight into
space and not only was you know that
took about thirty years to pull off
getting myself into space however I
think that's pretty good I mean
considering the that I'm still you know
I'm under the number 500 for a number of
people who have been into space so I
think the probability of pulling it off
at all was pretty daunting so I still
feel pretty darn good about thirty years
being all that was required to get there
and of course when I went I didn't know
that the private space industry could
pull it off at all or that frankly it
could continue or what role it would
play in the future as it's now playing
out what I'm actually very excited about
is that you know not only has this
journey allowed me to go but I'm
actually extremely bullish on not only
the role that they are playing now for
example with the XPrize we've you know
scaled composites spaceship one is now
hanging in Smithsonian virgins now
buying spaceship twos you know
Elon Musk of SpaceX is already flying to
orbit will be taking cargo to Bangalore
the ISS or NASA under the I think
brilliantly conceived cots program which
is something of a big fan of but also a
lot of the other suborbital makers
whether it's Blue Origin X Corps or one
of my favorites armadillo at a Dallas
armadillo aerospace you know those guys
are all now going to be making journeys
back and forth to space and not just
suborbital II but most all of them have
plans to continue on to orbit and as you
might imagine my life since my flight
has been often to come to places and
times like this to speak about the
evolving business of space or to
brainstorm about possible ways to
monetize space when you get there and
people even today have a challenge the
students here at MIT to come up with
ideas for how to capitalize on access to
space and I have to say that I actually
think that people are challenging
students often with the wrong question
because I think that the probability of
students being able to justify tens of
millions of dollars per person to orbit
is actually unlikely I think that the
firm especially as a private enterprise
investor that that's a very difficult
nut to crack I instead would rephrase
the question
which is you know I I myself am on my
own flight did work that paid millions
of dollars not tens of millions but at
least a significant percentage of my
flight cost and if we can get flight
costs down to a mere millions of dollars
per person then an interesting event
will occur which is the the these
changing of positions of the cost of
access and the value you can return with
and I believe that will happen within
the next five to ten years and I believe
that this fledgling private industry
that I'm a part of is already on the
journey to making that happen and and so
my challenge to the industry and to
students is to help to help that journey
along to help cause help bring into
being something that in my mind is
inevitable
and so the question is not whether it
will be cut whether it will come but
when it will come and who will be a part
of it so my challenge again to MIT
students specifically is to is to become
part of that journey and my challenge to
government space programs in private and
what I call traditional aerospace is to
find a way to partner with and
capitalize and take advantage of the
technologies that this fledgling
industry is bringing to bear versus
resist it or ignore it
thank you Richard out since you've
recently been up and down and that's not
a golf shot by the way the there are a
couple of questions that came in about
safety and in the importance of safety
in the human program you rode up and
down on an extraordinarily reliable
vehicle it doesn't happen to be the one
we operate you want to comment about
sort of what you think are the risks and
rewards and and the safety
considerations for a second well like
you mentioned I was I was lucky enough
to travel on a Soyuz which is actually a
phenomenally reliable and safe vehicle
you know I think the Russians having a
vastly underrated by the what I'll call
the general American public Space Launch
System you know even I thought of the
Soyuz as an old system until you get
there and start training on it you
realize it's actually been updated
constantly through its evolution and
even though its physical profile is
similar it's they've continued to
improve the quality and safety of that
machine you know quite a bit but when
you talk about safety in the general
purpose you know I there's no question
that you know you're gonna do you're
gonna travel into space you need to do
it cost effectively you need to do it
safely and you have a real good purpose
to be there and I think that's something
that that that that at least the
American public can't see very well yet
and if and I think we've not done a
great job as as an industry to either
prove the case for it or it or the
ratings communicate that to the general
put to the general public
but as we build new space vehicles
whether they're the man systems NASA is
going to build or some of these more
barnstorming oriented capabilities
that's this new space industries going
to build there's no question that there
will be a new phase of risk you know if
we're at least for the first dozen or
two flights of any of these vehicles the
the precise math of the risk is going to
be unknown and so therefore I think
there's a reasonable probability that we
will have fatalities for example but I
think there's no question that that is
worthwhile and I personally would take
those risks myself on some of these new
fledgling technologies that come into
existence and I think that ultimately
only by what I'll call democratizing
access to space by having multiple
vendors competing to keep the price down
competing to keep safety up will we
ultimately find the best access to space
Thank You Erica you're the token young
person on the panel here so I asked you
to think about how we can engage the
youth of America in thinking about the
future there are endless and in fact in
President Obama's presentation at the
National Academy numerous citations to
the degree to which Apollo excited the
youth of America inspired us to study
what's now called STEM science
technology engineering mathematics and
yet I find in dealing with our students
here they're not really very excited by
the current plan they sort of think it
looks like something their grandfather
did or maybe their father did what do
you think Erica well first of all let me
just say it's an absolute honor to be up
here
I've been sitting down from last night
and this morning watching is one after
another of my heroes came up on stage
and said in these seats that I was
thinking to myself oh my this is gonna
be an incredible place to be so we've
already asked those who have helped
create the history of space to stand up
but could everyone who was born after
Apollo 11 launched please stand
for those of us that were born after
Apollo started this is this is a given
we've been to them and we're going to go
back to the moon this is a part of our
generations heritage so I welcome all of
you who are who were standing to join me
because this is our future to create we
have some really big shoes to fill and
some really incredible opportunities so
I was asked to think about how we
recreate the spirit of Apollo and I
think it fundamentally takes three
things we need to amaze people again we
need to engage people again and we need
to connect with the next generation if
we look at Gallup polls over the last 20
years the American public is actually
fairly strongly in support of NASA and
in support of space exploration
the latest polls for the vision for
Space Exploration show 67 70 65 large
overwhelming majorities of the public
support what NASA does but there was a
recent study of 18 to 24 year olds and
it asked them what they supported and
when you look at it only 1/3 actually
supported returning to the moon 27% of
the 18 to 24 year olds that were
surveyed had doubts about the fact that
we had ever been to the moon that's over
a quarter of the young people in this
country they were surveyed have doubts
that we ever went and it made me stop
and think why you know for me this is an
absolute given but for a generation that
grew up with challenger with Columbia
with a space station that's been
hamstrung by budget and schedule
overruns it's no wonder that they doubt
that were capable of doing incredible
things I think if we want to get the
next generation engaged we have to do
amazing things again and we have to take
back the story line and talk about
what's hard and I think that you know
Kennedy had it right
we were we were going to go into space
because it was the difficult thing to do
and that that was how we inspired the
next generation and that challenges are
good wouldn't President Bush stood up to
announce the vision for Space
Exploration
let me just quote from
said we will begin the effort quickly
using existing programs and personnel
and we will make steady progress that's
not really we're going to go to the moon
in the next decade it's not inspiring
it's not challenging it is challenging
to do but what we need to do is we need
to take back that storyline and start to
talk about the challenging things
because if we can amaze the youth then
they will do incredible things we also
have to engage the youth as we've heard
a couple of times the average age in
Mission Control during the Apollo 11
mission was somewhere between 26 and 28
right now if you look around NASA
there's less than 20% of NASA is under
the age of 40 if we want to be inspiring
the next generation we have to be
engaging them we have they have to
believe that they can go and do these
things that they can be a part of this
new vision so we have to do amazing
things we need to engage the next
generation and doing them and we need to
reconnect with the American public how
many of you remember reading Life
magazine during the Apollo era or
watching launches on the evening news
well magazines Life magazine not so much
anymore
the average age and in recent surveys of
people who watch the evening news is
over the age of 60 we need to find new
ways of communicating the incredible
things that we're doing with the
generation of tomorrow we need to use
Flickr and YouTube and iPhone apps and
texting questions to our moderator and
and tweeting anyone who happens to be on
Twitter today we're at hash giant leaps
in that vein I think it's time for space
exploration to become interactive again
and what Richard was talking about the
emergence of the commercial spaceflight
industry is really an incredible thing
in September of 2004 I had the great
chance to go out to the Mojave Desert
for the launch of spaceship one and I
stood there and I was stoked I was
really excited to be there but I was
also watching the people around me and
we saw you know Scott Crossfield who
flew the x-15 and the NASA Administrator
Sean O'Keefe and a half a dozen
astronauts I tell you they were kids in
a candy store and these were people who
had seen hundreds of launches you know
satellites and shuttles and Mercury and
Apollo and this is something new and
this was the changing the whole game
and I think that the the promise of
being able to open up space to the to
the public is something that's really
really interesting and important in 2007
the XPrize Foundation announced its next
space challenge along with Google 30
million dollars in prizes for the
private explorers to return to the moon
to Rove around the lunar surface and to
broadcast back HD video and we've seen
18 different teams from around the world
that are coming out to compete in that
and I'll go ahead and shout out to the
folks that are working on the next giant
leap team here in Boston students and
faculty at MIT at Draper lab at Aurora
flight sciences with the Sierra Nevada
Corporation you may have seen some of
their prototype hardware hopping around
over at lunch and this is the real deal
this is how you invest in the next
generation you challenge them to do
something amazing you engage them from
the day one all the way through
operating the hardware and you share
their stories you let them share their
stories in ways that resonate through
blogs and tweets and YouTube videos so
I'll just close with a quick personal
story this January I had the incredibly
humbling experience of being invited to
Houston for the first round of
interviews in the astronaut selection
process and this is an absolute dream
come true but the the best memory for me
was Ivan we got called at dawn to come
to work out with the personal trainers
at the astronaut gym and we walked in
and they sent us off to our locker rooms
and it was like that scene in every
sports movie you've ever seen where the
rookie walks in and goes oh my gosh
that's Jill White's Locker and that's
Jim Green but for me it was Eileen
Collins and Genesis and Katie Katie
Coleman and sunny Williams and I'm a
space geek through and through and I I
know that today I'm preaching to the
choir but we're here today because we
believe that amazing things are possible
again and so I think that the challenge
is to share what we know to be possible
with the rest of the public and to
invite the next generation to take the
reigns and come along for the ride
so what in addition twittering and
texting what could we do to sort of
reach out and grab this generation I
mean it's it's remarkable to me how
often and how deeply it is felt inside
the beltway that the primary motivation
the primary national urgency to have a
successful human spaceflight program is
to inspire the youth and if we don't
have one that inspires the youth it
erodes that that enormous base of policy
support can you think of a few things we
might actually do fly students there we
go first and foremost and I don't care
if it's sub or or fly students
experiments for students experiments
that's why students we're coming to the
age where we can do that
and I think the add minutes of orbital
flight we should be fine students even
that Padawan next you got to fly in G
and I think that when we do incredible
things again the students will be
excited again we have to learn how they
tell those stories do incredible things
and fly them that's your advice simple
good formula David you've built up a
successful commercial enterprise doing
business and space from a garage up
based operation 20 years ago twenty-five
or seven years ago how are companies in
your category gonna contribute to this
great endeavor ed it's 27 years two
months nine days and four hours and 20
minutes but who's counting good
afternoon everybody I the tagline on the
program for today perspective is
everything I think is is important and
perhaps to add a little bit of
perspective from the standpoint of
several other sectors of planet Earth's
space Enterprise I would begin by
talking a little bit about the current
state of affairs in the commercial space
sector commercial space today revolves
almost exclusively around satellites
that provide communication
Asians navigation and imagery services
to consumers on earth and over the 40
years or so since they began in the late
60s they've grown to represent the
largest and the fastest growing sector
of the space market today based on the
numbers that we've we compile which are
a bit more conservative than some that
have been published last year
individuals companies and government
agencies spent about a hundred and
eighty-five billion dollars on space
related activities around the world and
these categories of communications
navigation and imagery generated about a
hundred and ten billion of that total so
roughly 60% which which makes everyday
uses of space for these kind of
applications a little over three point
six times as big today as all scientific
and human spaceflight combined and heat
and even two and a quarter times larger
than the amount of money we spend on
important military and intelligence
space activities in addition over the
last 15 years these commercial
applications have grown at about twice
the rate of government applications last
year they expanded about 9% compared to
the prior year compared to four or five
percent growth across all the various
governmental space activities now you
may wonder how could this be possible
well Ed's example earlier of a New
England boy professor now at MIT
commuting all of three or four miles
back and forth in in Cambridge listening
to satellite radio is really the answer
to that there's some 350 million people
on earth today that everyday receive
information and one type or another
directly from satellites and that
doesn't count
several billion people that receive it
indirectly when we watch The Weather
Channel
or we turn on our TV sets when we're
subscribers to cable terrestrial cable
systems commercial space systems have
achieved these these impressive economic
results because of a steady pace of
advances in technology that have been
applied primarily to reducing cost over
the last 30 years the capital cost per
the transponder year of satellite
communications capacity has fallen by a
factor of 25 so if you do the math that
says year end and year out some years
have been better than others the
commercial satellite communication
industry has improved its primary
economic figure of Merit by 10 or 11
percent per year when you do that for
three decades you produce 25 fold
improvements in what matters to
customers this has not been the result
of any single breakthrough in technology
it's been a series of sometimes large
sometimes relatively incremental
improvements in a variety of of both
space segment technologies as well as
the ground equipment that many of us
used to receive this information from
satellites in addition to the
contributions of well-established
companies that grew up during World War
two the Cold War or the Apollo program
during the 1960's many of these advances
have also been propelled by a great deal
of entrepreneurial activity in the last
40 years by my count there have been
almost 350 new companies started and
we've seen about 75 of those companies
succeed to the point of actually being
able to build launch or operate at least
one privately owned satellite the
largest of those today's today is an
American company that broadcast hundreds
of channels of entertainment television
2 to 1/2 meter diameter dishes
throughout the US and other locations in
North America one of the other large
ones generating something like three and
a half billion dollars a year sells GPS
enabled smartphones and other consumer
products that use the air force's global
positioning system in ways that were
never imagined when that system was
conceived back in the late 1960s and and
1970s
in economic terms then the commercial
space sector today generates by far the
highest value space benefits based on on
the way markets assess these benefits
while most of us here would would
probably ascribe a much higher value and
we'd be willing to pay a much greater
expense for our terrific space and earth
science programs that are carried out
robotically the fact of the matter is we
have a democracy and in the political
give-and-take of our democracy we have
assigned a value to that in the United
States of about one dollar and fifty
cents per month per citizen if we throw
in the weather satellites will pick that
we'll pick that up to about a dollar in
75 cents per month per citizen all of us
would agree that's got to be the best
bargain we've ever seen but our
democracy assigns that value in its
allocation of resources to the robotic
space program the human space program
does a little better but not a lot for
for at least most of the last 30 years
nASA has in many cases been right on the
ragged edge of doing what can be done
with the resources allotted to it in
today's dollars the country democratic
process that we follow in our country
assigns of value of about three dollars
per month persists and to our human
spaceflight programs the defense and
intelligence programs in space which
have played a role that is not widely
recognized
throughout our country and allowing the
Cold War to come to a peaceful
conclusion and to do many other things
in more modern times to protect our
country's security and that of those
young men and women that we send
overseas to be on the frontlines
generates a little higher perceived
value as a country we spend about $10 a
month per citizen on all of our space
defense and intelligence programs well
of course if you multiply any of these
numbers by 300 million people
you get sizable sums what is significant
though to me is that in a somewhat quiet
way over the last 40 years commercial
space ventures through the development
of direct broadcast television handheld
satellite navigators satellite radio
satellite imaging have found markets
that that where customers voluntarily
spend between 15 and 25 dollars per
month per subscriber for space delivered
commercial services these areas I think
provide a very strong foundation for
growth across all sectors of the space
enterprise in the years ahead
now there's not a particularly easy fit
between the pressures and the demands of
many government space projects with
those that are carried out entirely by
the private sector for instance the the
private sector typically takes its
technology advances in small increments
the government often because we only get
the chance in the public sector to
develop one or maybe two new space
systems in a generation has to take a
little more risk sometimes as we
introduce new technology commercial
satellite systems have very well-defined
objectives they're implemented over a
two-year period and we almost never
change direction once we start a project
of course as you know public sector
ventures responding to a somewhat more
diverse set of constituencies often
a lot longer and do change their
objectives over time there are many
other reasons why there's not a
particularly natural fit between these
sectors but I am encouraged by progress
that's occurred over the last 10 or 15
years where the degree of intersection
and overlap between the sector's is
increasing today for instance almost 5
billion dollars will be spent this year
by government agencies in the United
States Europe and elsewhere buying from
commercial providers the products and
services that those providers also sell
to companies and individuals probably
the best single example of this is in
communications but there are other
examples NASA has another new program
underway now for commercial delivery of
cargo to the international space station
that will quickly develop into something
like a 1/2 billion dollar a year area of
intersection between those segments and
so with these and and other examples on
the horizon I am hopeful that we will
see more interaction between the 3
sectors of the space enterprise that
have largely grown apart over the past
40 years it was nope notable to me that
just a couple of months ago in
Washington I attended the the largest
commercial satellite conference of the
year which brings in all of the the
satellite commercial satellite owners
from all around the world attracted some
9,000 people to this conference the
third week of March two weeks later
attended the largest civil space
conference civil and military space
conference held in in the United States
and Colorado Springs it attracted about
7,000 people in these two sets one
numbering about 9,000 people the other
about 7,000 people I estimated there
there were about 300 people that
attended both conferences so we have we
have two worlds dealing with many of the
same underlying physical principles
engineering practices and technology
base who more or less don't speak to one
another
I'm hopeful that over the next decade
we'll find many more areas where these
these two worlds can intersect to the
benefit of both thank you very much Dave
you'll be you'd be happy to know that
due to those inspiring remarks the stock
closed up today sort of sounds like a
CEO doesn't it our final speaker is Jim
Crocker how can what we'll call big
aerospace respond to the needs of the
future of the program well thank you ed
for giving me five minutes to answer the
question of how we can reduce cost and
cycle time in the aerospace industry
there's another question that when you
actually was gonna say I think I can do
it but we'll take six minutes not five
so matter of fact unbeknownst to it I've
actually spent the last over 30 years of
my career actually thinking about this
problem and actually trying to do
something about it not at large
aerospace companies per se but large
aerospace medium aerospace government in
academia and in to startups so while in
five or six minutes I can only give you
a character tour of the question I think
before I give you the answer I have to
tell you what I think the problem is
well to begin with it's not how we build
satellites it's first of all how we
procure them because we buy them one at
a time I mean everybody here at MIT
knows the story of why pencils and
toothpicks and airliners cost so little
today and it's because fundamentally
Ford while watching the armored pig
plant disassemble pigs had the idea for
how to assemble cars and most of our
prosperity today comes about because of
the assembly line and all of the
associated improvements that we've made
over the decades to do that from pencils
to pigs to aerospace but with satellites
and with launch vehicles and with many
of the other things we buy them one at a
time now we try to improve that by
buying several at a time but in essence
we still build them one at a time
because we build them to replace the one
that's
going to fail and then we launch them on
a launch vehicle that we built one at a
time and it cost a lot and the other
secret is is even when we buy several of
them we don't build the same thing twice
the last time I looked the Hubble Space
Telescope was 2.4 meters in collecting
area and the James Webb is 6.5 that's
almost a mass factor 7 almost a order of
magnitude bigger and it's about the same
price but we never build the same thing
twice so we don't get the economies of
scale you know before you get too
depressed about that I think I can prove
to you that economies of scale would go
a long way to solve the problem because
Lockheed Martin built the Iridium
constellation of satellites over 90
satellites actually built by the company
launched in multiple launches with the
clusters of vehicles on each one and in
fact I've seen the numbers and they were
built for an order of magnitude less and
built at fixed price so so there is no
magic between big companies small
company it's theirs in this essence it
was just economies of scale now for
those of us who thought that if we built
it they would come the CubeSat earth of
today I think we had this wonderful
production line going we were building
these spacecraft and we just thought we
would just provide everybody with the
low cost spacecraft and low cost
launches that they needed and lo and
behold nobody showed up and we had to
shut the Iridium line down which which
Lockheed thought was uh was a great
waste because we had the volume but
there was no follow-on volume because no
one could find the application that like
iridium would require a large number of
satellites so he came down to a business
model so in both cases is how we buy and
what we use them for in the business
model had little to do with the
production the production was driven by
how we bought but Iridium demonstrated
in fact that you could do something so
we don't have the volume we don't buy
multiple satellites so what can we do
and in fact for the last several years
last almost decade at Lockheed Martin
we've been trying a couple of different
approaches which in fact
have been working and it's part of what
we're doing for Maria Zuber with the
Grail mission and that is we've been
moving the satellites to be very
software intensive anything that was
mechanical or electrical that we could
throw off the satellite and replace it
by software that's exactly what we've
done as a matter of fact it's been
extremely successful I was looking the
Viking Lander just the lander itself
depending on how you do inflation in
different numbers is well over a billion
dollars some people would say to
certainly north of a billion in current
year dollars just on February on March
25th not this previous but a year ago
which happened to be my daughter's
birthday we landed the Phoenix lander
she thinks we did this for her on Mars
on the polar region in that spacecraft
was under a hundred million dollars for
the lander portion so well over an order
magnitude improvement and fundamentally
it was done by changing electronics in
mechanical systems out for software I
had someone run a calculation for me and
I looked at over the last decade along a
box that is the size of the speaker that
you see in front of me we've been able
to reduce by software and in this case
I'm talking about programmable gate
arrays not just software to something
the size of your fingernail now it's not
just the box alone because the box area
that I'm talking about includes the
power system and electronics associated
with that that would have to power that
box as well so you can see an enormous
reduction and that's how we've gotten
most recently in the planetary
spacecraft the size weight volume and
thus cost down and we're trying to do
the same thing with with a constellation
with the Orion capsule it is going to be
extremely software intensive anything
you can do with software you do a
software last time I look software
doesn't weigh anything you can also
reuse it much more inexpensively as
tough as the as the industry software
and computer industry shows but that's
not enough to really continue driving
the cost down the other thing is
reusability and of course the Orion
capsule
be used several times just changing the
heat shield as well the Ares rocket of
course the Ares one is very similar to
the external SRBs on the shuttle which
parachute in get refueled and flown
again but unlike the shuttle I think
what we're doing correctly this time is
we're only reusing the expensive parts
the less expensive parts we're throwing
away
it's the expensive avionics parts that
we're trying to recover both in Ares as
well as in the SRB shuttle became so
expensive but Charles we tried to make
more of it reusable to many miracles yes
Maria would say to do and then so just
to sum it up I'd say software
reusability new business models and then
lastly the right mix of humans and
robots it's not humans or robots as
humans and robots working together and I
think as we've demonstrated on the
Hubble servicing mission some very
innovative ways that we can get to a
cost that while it's not going to be as
cheap as flying from here to Europe on
an airliner might get us to the point
where we can do more with the dollars
that the public is willing to spend to
allow quite frankly all of us to carry
them on this journey of exploration and
discovery
well let me try and wrap up there's
excitement in space there's opportunity
in space there's understanding of the
universe in space we should send
students into space I didn't hear anyone
violate law number one I heard lots of
people thinking about how we design our
space missions to satisfy the
stakeholders the American public that
fund them and in fact direct references
to considering the investment that we're
making on behalf of the nation I didn't
hear anyone violate law number two which
is that primarily we move bits around in
space to gain information and to make
money and of course we have to build
systems that move bits but the bits are
fundamentally what the recurring value
is created by so I'll summarize the
afternoon session by giving you my law
number three which is that all
successful human spaceflight endeavors
are fundamentally instruments of foreign
policy that Apollo was an instrument of
foreign policy that shuttle was a
vehicle by which many nations launched
their first astronaut in fact more than
50% of people in the UK in poles there
believed that the UK launched mike foale
into space he's become such a popular
figure in the UK the the British
astronaut the International Space
Station version one created by the
Reagan administration was viewed as the
way to collect those battling against
the evil empire in a grand alliance to
work together in space the International
Space Station version 2 created by the
Clinton administration in 1993 was
predicated on the fact that the
International Space Station was a good
way to engage the no longer occupied
building the the Soviet space vehicles
Russian space engineers into building a
joint venture and therefore keeping them
away from building things like
intermediate-range ballistic missiles
for third world nations and i think the
fundamental question in some sense is
that the Augustine committee has in
front of it or one of the fundamental
questions which was touched on in many
of the questions that we didn't have
time to get to today is how how will we
make this next incarnation of human
spaceflight both important to the
American people important to the
scientific community important to the
economic community and fundamentally a
successful instrument of foreign policy
so thank you very much for coming today
thank the panel and the organizers
oh let me add my thanks to our keynote
speaker Maria thank you to our panelists
thank you all and Edie super job
moderating very well done we have had a
very busy day that's not unusual at MIT
but I'm gonna make my closing remarks
very very short this has been an
opportunity for us to bring together a
couple threads in in a new way and I
hope that you found it engaging and
interesting I've certainly found it very
engaging and interesting it's now time
to sort of switch into celebration mode
fully as people are aware we have a very
special show at Symphony Hall on tonight
I want to provide just a little bit of
direction to you the most important
thing that you can remember from me in
my closing remarks is that if you have
questions about transportation go to the
registration desk which is in Johnson
and they will help direct people in
appropriate places for buses there's
transport that will go to and from
hotels and Symphony Hall there's
transport that will go to and from here
and there are a and dinner for everyone
over in Johnson and then there are some
people who will go to a department
dinner just before the symphony show and
if you are going to the department
dinner the Hunziker dinner look for the
signs for that or ask some of the people
outside who will help so there's about
four different vectors of transportation
and the most important thing you can do
is follow signs and ask for help
so that's the bit of housekeeping that I
wanted to do as I said I would keep my
closing remarks short so I will
officially close the symposium I I do so
with a no small amount of a personal
admiration
and inspiration from all of you who
contributed to the Paolo program and the
space program since that time as well as
today's leaders who shared with us much
of their wisdom and thoughts and the
real inspiration for all of us is that
that group of individuals that Erica had
stand up who were born after the Apollo
11 landing the real inspiration is that
you'll do something great in the next 40
years for us so with that I close the
symposium and thank you all
[Applause]